kommen wir zu schockierenden bildern aus
amsterdam dort in amsterdam wird ein
23-jähriger deutscher erschossen von
polizisten
niederländische zeitungen berichten habe
der verwirrte mann die polizisten mit
einem messer bedroht und dann gedroht
sich selbst die kehle durchzuschneiden
alles festgehalten auf video die bilder
könnten verstörend würden drei schüsse
töten den 23-jährigen deutschen samuel
es in amsterdam
doch wie ist es dazu gekommen gegen
16.30 werden polizeibeamte auf den mann
aufmerksam der ein messer in der hand
hält sie sprechen ihn an
doch er wirkt verwirrt und reagiert
nicht auf die ansprache durch die
polizisten
er droht sich selbst mit dem messer zu
verletzen
fast 15 minuten lang versuchen die
polizisten auf einem hinterhof auf den
halbnackten mann einzureden
ein versuch den mann mit hilfe eines
polizeihundes unter kontrolle zu
bekommen scheitert dann fallen drei
schüsse
trotz sofort eingeleiteter
wiederbelebungsversuche stirbt samuel es
nun ermittelt die kriminalpolizei wegen
des schusswaffengebrauchs rom coups ist
der reporter in amsterdam und mir jetzt
live zugeschaltet ganz herzlich
willkommen bei bild in ihrem hinterhof
hat sich das ganze ereignete
dieser schreckliche zwischenfall und sie
wissen mehr zu dem getöteten zu den
hintergründen möglicherweise dieser
tragischen aktion der trage ich habe ich
war arbeiten zu hause hier in den
amtsräumen wie auch meine kollegen euro
zeitung gegen koller und wann ich
beschreibe donnerstagmittag und
ausgeschrieben vom sammel sms mit einer
größe messechefs messer 30 zentimeter
hat der politiker mir gesagt und er war
nicht stabil
815 auf reden wandelte der samba in die
richtung in die nähe von die agenten und
softgetränke policeman ensheim us some
point of view funktion bei die beide
teams bei einem freund joel dazu shops
in der indie video image of the pops am
uhr also kurz übersetzt translation also
der täter der getötete der hat
tatsächlich einen polizisten angegriffen
hat ihnen tatsächlich mit dem messer
auch verletzt und das war schließlich
dann ja war dann schließlich der
ausschlaggebende punkt für die
polizisten die schüsse in eigensicherung
abzugeben
noch eine frage an sie herr koops man
sieht den einsatz des hundes der ja
eigentlich dort die situation beruhigen
sollte das hat offensichtlich nicht
richtig funktioniert war das der
eskalierende moment so zu sagen yes we
have in bergnot ps2 andere research
in die brüche am rand der beliebten
treff ist aspekt in dem ausländer
meeting bei his friends of seven friends
since the most of them are looking for
him der schiefen report des family was
away community dazu herbst looking
statements are found in the wall street
view tunes of the people cope bestätigte
das halt der einsatz der des
polizeihundes da schiefgelaufen ist das
jetzt unabhängige ermittlung von der
oberen behörde dann jetzt durchgeführt
werden die schauen sich genau den
polizeieinsatz an und schauen wie das
ganze da eskalieren konnte um kurze
reporter in amsterdam ganz herzlichen
dank für ihre information zu diesem
tragischen fall